fliegen wir jetzt zum mars eine neue ära
der raumfahrt hat diese woche begonnen
zum ersten mal seit neun jahren flog
eine besatzung amerikanischer piloten
vom amerikanischen boden in den weltraum
und das zum ersten mal mit einer
raumkapsel eines privaten
raumfahrtunternehmen spacex und damit
rückt die besiedlung des mars jetzt in
erreichbare nähe und es gab den ersten
kriminalfall im weltraum
wieso weshalb warum klicksafe user in
der spektakulären edition zukunft
rowohlt hier gibt es drei mal pro woche
spannende wissenschafts videos abonniert
den kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur
so verpasst ihr nichts los geht's
herzlich willkommen
das heutige video ist eines der themen
aus meinem neuen buch bei aufzügen den
weltraum erschienen im rowohlt verlag
und in diesem buch geht es um unsere
zukunft um realistische szenarien wie
sie aussehen könnte
wissenschaftlich begründet wer so einen
blick in die zukunft werfen möchte der
sollte hier auf den link zum buch und
ami klicken
lange sah so aus als würde die raumfahrt
auf der stelle treten die usa hatten
noch nicht mal mehr ein transportmittel
um astronauten und astronauten ins
weltall zu bringen
nach dem letzten flug eines space
shuttles im juli 2011 stand die nasa mit
leeren händen da es schien so als sei
die bemannte raumfahrt für die westliche
welt einfach zu teuer lediglich das
sojus programm konnte weiter genutzt
werden und nur china schickte noch
taikonauten ins all
die astronauten und kosmonauten ja dort
genannt werden auch für die
internationale raumstation iss ist keine
nachfolge in sicht flüge zum mond finden
seit mehr als 40 jahren nicht mehr statt
und bei der nasa gibt es immer wieder
budget diskussion steht die raumfahrt
also am scheideweg werden wir es
vielleicht nie schaffen die erde in
nennenswerter zahl zu verlassen ist die
wirtschaftsleistung unserer zivilisation
einfach zu klein um raumfahrt im großen
stil zu ermöglichen als 1969 die ersten
menschen auf dem mond landeten sahen die
perspektiven noch ganz anders aus nichts
schien unmöglich und als dann die space
shuttles an den start gingen erlagen
alle der illusion was muss man sagen
dass raumfahrt jetzt alltäglich werden
damit war 2011 schluss das space shuttle
programm war entgegen den ersten
kalkulationen viel zu teuer und mit zwei
abstürzen auf wie zu unsicher zwei
katastrophen
die sich in das gedächtnis der gesamten
menschheit eingebrannt haben sind wir zu
weit gegangen ist die menschheit an ihre
grenzen gestoßen
lange schien es so doch dann tauchten
ein paar pioniere am horizont auf die in
den letzten jahren teils unglaubliches
geschafft haben ebenso komisch wie die
bilder der space-shuttle abstürze wurde
im positiven sinne die parallele landung
zweier booster der falcon heavy 2018
nachdem sie von ihrer rakete abgesprengt
worden waren die trägerrakete des
privaten unternehmens spacex von allen
masc erbrachte den beweis dass die
zukunft der raumfahrt nicht vorbei ist
es war das letzte zeichen dafür dass
wirklich ein neues zeitalter angebrochen
ist und 2020 neun jahre nach dem ende
des space shuttle programms sind jetzt
zum ersten mal im regulären betrieb wie
der amerikanische astronauten mit einer
raumkapsel zur internationalen
raumstation geflogen und auch hier war
der herstellers spacex und das ist kein
nationales ereignis diese kapseln die
crew dragon ist ein meilenstein der
raumfahrt keine 100 knöpfe und
anzeigeinstrumente ein smartes
raumschiff mit flachbildschirm und
wenigen bedienelementen und es bietet
platz für sieben passagiere
diesmal sind vier astronauten
mitgeflogen wir brechen in den weltraum
auf was vor wenigen jahren noch als
utopisch hat ist urplötzlich denkbar und
könnte morgen schon wirklichkeit werden
stephen hawking lag wahrscheinlich gar
nicht so falsch mit seiner vor seinem
tod noch einmal bekräftigten forderungen
dass wir zu neuen welten aufbrechen
müssen wenn wir es nicht wagen werden
wir früher oder später hier auf der erde
durch den klimawandel ein supervulkan
einen asteroiden oder eine pandemie
vernichtet eine ganze reihe von
zukunftsforschern rechnet damit in den
nächsten jahrhunderten oder
jahrtausenden zb karl sagen oder
michio kaku eines spezies die dauerhaft
überleben will muss in die weiten des
weltraums aufbrechen hawking gibt uns
sogar nur noch 100 jahre die chancen
dass das machbar ist werden tatsächlich
immer größer zum einen wird auf immer
mehr planeten und monden wie dem mars
oder dem mond wasser entdeckt dass wir
auf missionen nutzen könnten zum anderen
wird raumfahrt durch pioniere wie ihnen
maske oder jeff bezos mit ihren
unternehmen spacex oder blue origin
immer preiswerter und das ist
entscheidend für die eroberung des
weltraums durch die riesigen schritte
die dort in den letzten jahren technisch
und auch finanziell gemacht wurden haben
sich die möglichkeiten grund sich
geändert was vor einigen jahren noch
eine unmögliche kraftanstrengung gewesen
wäre wird jetzt fast schon wie eine
spazierfahrt rohstoffabbau auf dem mond
warum nicht eine maß kolonie
da schicken wir direkt mal 1000 raketen
und auch die sicher noch utopische
perspektive eines aufzuges in den
weltraum scheint realistischer zu werden
während der start einer saturn 5 noch
rund eine milliarde dollar gekostet hat
sind die kosten bei den falken raketen
von spacex inzwischen auf unter 100
millionen euro gefallen neil armstrong
hatte ihnen musk noch mit auf den weg
gegeben dass er seine ehrgeizigen ziele
erreichen würde aber das scheint man es
nur noch mehr motiviert haben schon
jetzt hat der fortschritte erzielt die
nicht nur neil armstrong für unmöglich
gehalten hätte und er ist nicht der
einzige in aufbruchstimmung ganz konkret
wird gerade an einer raumstation für den
mond orbit gearbeitet dem deep space
gateway inzwischen in lunar orbiter
plattform gateway umgetauft es ist ein
projekt an dem nasa esa die russische
roskosmos die japanische yakuza und die
kanadische csi arbeiten die raumstation
im orbit soll den mond erforschen später
eine mondstation versorgung und als
basis auch flüge zu weiter entfernten
zielen in unserem sonnensystem
ermöglichen missionen die von dort
starten benötigen viel weniger
treibstoff da sie nicht von der
gravitation der erde gehemmt werden die
nasa plant die station im low orbit des
modus hier heben sich die
anziehungskräfte von erde und mond für
einen dritten körper denn mit ihnen die
sonne umkreist auf schon ab 2022 sollen
mit dem bau der stationen begonnen
werden ende des jahrzehnts sollen sie
bereits einsatzbereit sein und damit
wäre der betrieb einer mondstation
möglich vom deep space gateway könnten
kleinere länder mit relativ geringem
aufwand nachschub und besatzung zum mond
und auch wieder zurück bringen
alternativ oder zusätzlich biete sich
hier auch schon der bau eines weltraum
aufzuges an da der aufwand dafür
ungleich geringer ist als auf der erde
die ersten beiden module der raumstation
eines zur energieversorgung und ein
kleinerer wohnbereich sollen nach
derzeitiger planung übrigens mit der
feldjacke rakete in den orbit befördert
der lunar orbiter plattform gateway und
eine mondstation könnten wiederum das
sprungbrett für eine mars-mission seien
ihnen musk ist sogar noch ungeduldiger
wobei seine zeitfenster angaben ja immer
etwas kritisch gesehen werden müssen er
will schon 2022 zum mars sein starship
eine neuentwicklung soll einen baldigen
flug zum mars möglich machen wobei das
datum inzwischen von der website
entfernt wurde einst waren ihm aber
lassen
der bau in serie hat schon begonnen
allerdings explodieren die prototypen
noch häufiger es ist musk der mit den
erwähnten 1000 raketen den mars
besiedeln will das volumen seines stars
chips ist mit 825 kubikmetern größer als
das eines airbus a380 die stars chips
sind damit größer als alles was menschen
bisher ins all geschossen haben
118 meter ist ihre gesamthöhe
einschließlich der antrieb stufe um
überhaupt zum mars zu gelangen fliegt
das da stimmt erstmal in eine
erdumlaufbahn und trifft dort auf
treibstofftanks die vorher in den
erdorbit geschossen worden sind sie sind
gefüllt mit methan und sauerstoff und
treiben die rakete auf dem flug zum mars
an die ersten missionen sollen nach
wasser und rohstoffen und gefahren für
menschen suchen die ersten menschen die
dazu mars fliegen sollen produzieren
dort den treibstoff für den rückflug zur
erde vier stars chips sollen zunächst
zum mars fliegen zwei benannt und zwei
und wenn man mit diesen flügen soll dann
die erste kolonie aufgebaut werden
die starship sollen wieder verwendbar
sein um die kosten niedrig zu halten mit
jedem flug plant mast danach 100
menschen bloß fragt in 40 kabinen zum
mars zu fliegen
die starship sind zusätzlich mit großen
gemeinschafts bereichen und fachräumen
ausgestattet doch es gibt auch ungeahnte
hürden auf dem weg sei sie haben sich
erst in den letzten jahren durch den
betrieb der internationalen raumstation
gezeigt unser organismus reagiert viel
heftiger auf den längeren aufenthalt in
der schwerelosigkeit als bisher
angenommen es fängt an mit den augen
zwei drittel aller astronauten und
astronautinnen berichten von stark
nachlassen der sehkraft die augäpfel
werden auf der rückseite flacher und
verschieben dadurch gerät mit den
lichtempfindlichen zellen ursache sind
wahrscheinlich veränderungen des drucks
in der hirn und rückenmarksflüssigkeit
auf der erde wenn gravitation und
stärkere bewegungen auf das gehirn
einwirken soll die hirnflüssigkeit die
sie dämpfen in der schwerelosigkeit
verliert sie letztlich ihre funktion
besatzungsmitglieder die länger auf der
internationalen raumstation bahn hatten
danach deutlich mehr hirnflüssigkeit und
die verformung der augäpfel geht nach
rückkehr zur erde eben nicht bei allen
zurück dazu kommen muskel und
knochenschwund die schwächung des
immunsystems die kosmische strahlung
könnte und europa machen und nimmst
wurde noch das weltraum schieber
entdeckt im weltraum nimmt die
körpertemperatur über 200 monate um ein
grad zu und pendelt sich dann ein bei
körperlicher beanspruchung steigt sie
auf über 40 grad und das ist extrem
gefährlich wir wissen dass am 41 grad
celsius körpertemperatur lebensgefahr
besteht körpereigene eiweiße verfestigen
sich dann um verstopfen die gefäße und
körperliche anstrengung ist wiederum
wichtig um den knochen und muskeln bau
aufzuhalten er kann damit sogar komplett
gestoppt werden doch der preis könnte
tödlich ist fieber sein
gleichwohl wird es immer normaler im
weltraum zu leben mit
begleiterscheinungen wie sie auch auf
der erde gibt alexander gerst ist der
erste deutsche kommandant der
internationalen raumstation iss gewesen
mehr als 200 tage hatte am ende
insgesamt im rahmen von vier missionen
auf der iss verbracht zum vergleich
kommen wenn sie in der gesetze umsetzen
für eine reise zum mars 200 bis 240 tage
an elem us wird es mit seiner großen
geht den 80 bis 120 tagen schaffen
alexander gerst war übrigens der erste
astronaut der im weltraum ermitteln
musste was geschah in der sojus kapsel
die ihn zur iss gebracht hatte plötzlich
endlich aus der ice es nämlich die
atemluft das team musste das leck finden
und spürte es in der soers kapsel ms09
auf das erschreckende es war ein loch
und dieses loch war von menschenhand
gebohrt worden
was ist dort also passiert war es eine
schlampigkeit auf der erde bei der
fertigung der kapsel
oder war es sogar sabotage die russische
weltraumagentur roskosmos hat von gast
und seinen kollegen proben der außenhaut
rund um das loch zur untersuchung
bekommen und die mit rigorosen chef
roskosmos meint dass die ursache für das
loch klar sei er würde sie jedoch nicht
veröffentlichen
es gibt also noch viele risiken bei
längeren raumfahrt missionen einige
können wir vielleicht minimieren mit
anderen müssen wir im weltall
wahrscheinlich leben dieses und viele
andere themen aus unserer zukunft findet
ihr in meinem neuen buch per aufzug in
den weltraum
wie hat es euch eigentlich gefallen
schreibt es gerne hier und das video und
wer es noch nicht hat
einfach hier klicken oder zur nächsten
buchhandlung gehen oder in die video
beschreibung vielen dank dass er dabei
seid und liegt im treu bleibt bis dann
bleibt dran